visitin Trump and Joe Biden already
trading blows and what could be a
preview of a 2020 showdown president
Trump going after the former VP on
Twitter saying quote the media fake news
is pushing sleepy Joe hard funny I'm
only here because of Biden and Obama
they didn't do the job and now you had
Trump who is getting it done big time
end quote meanwhile Biden hitting back
during his first campaign rally in
Pittsburgh just moments ago I make no
apologies I am a union man folks if I'm
gonna be able to beat Donald Trump in
2020 it's gonna happen here
this comes amid a new report that may
explain why Biden's 2020 run hasn't been
endorsed by President Obama according to
a new report Obama tried to talk Biden
out of running in 2016 because he
thought Hillary Clinton was more
electable Kennedy I don't think there's
any doubt about that I mean I think that
the Democratic establishment coalesced
around Hillary pretty early yeah it's so
easy at this point to play Monday early
evening quarterback and it's so easy to
say you know obviously Hillary Clinton
wasn't the most electable candidate but
she had already had a newly successful
run I understand that but it also goes
to show that the Biden is a much more
loyal person than President Obama and we
see that now because President Obama
won't even endorse you know his suppose
a good friend his loyal VP who served
him proudly for eight years so I think
it's an interesting dynamic there and it
also goes to show and we've seen this
time and time again
President Obama Obama really good at
getting himself elected terrible at
getting other people elected Jesse I
think lots of people on the Democratic
side view the establishment that
coalesced around Hillary in 16 as
thinking it's good to have an open
primary this time let the blows fall
where they may and we'll get the best
candidate when Biden really needs the
Obama endorsement he can make that phone
call right now it's a little too early
for that to happen but if you think
about it when Barack Obama was thinking
about who's gonna win my third term
who's gonna cement my legacy in there he
didn't think about Joe who'd been with
him for eight long years and that's
pretty significant I just saw that rally
that rally was weak there was not a lot
of people there the people behind him
looked bored he looked like he was
trying to counteract the sleepy Joe
narrative that had been forming he was
stumbling all over his lines couldn't
read the prompter well he was stepping
on things he just did not look polished
it looked extremely rusty and a lot of
the people back in hair and makeup said
they thought that he had fillers in and
Botox you know I didn't say that but a
lot of people in there and make
and they know because they look at faces
all day long I will say this though
about you he cannot get a crowd are
people gonna drive miles and miles to
listen to Joe Biden no are people gonna
get Joe Biden tattoos on their backs
like they did with Donald Trump and
Barack Obama no he doesn't get ratings
he doesn't sell books he doesn't get
clicks this guy is a candidate by
default and I think you're gonna see
that develop more and more so you don't
think he gets the nomination I'm not
saying that but I don't see the
excitement there there's no movement
there's no doctrine there's no there's
nothing there well Dana do you think you
see I happen to disagree and based on
sources I have to say that in fact Biden
and Obama get along pretty good but do
you think it makes a difference well I
also think it could hurt him okay so
there are a lot of people in the
Democratic Party who think that Obama
was not progressive enough and they're
mad at him for that president biden is
going to have to excite the base if you
can on his own I also think we have to
remember that in 2015 when the decision
was were being made of who's going to
run Joe Biden had just lost his son we
all know that was a very public grieving
and we shared in that grief with him and
I think it could be in the history books
might show us in the future if President
Obama ever talks about it what he was
thinking in terms of trying to perhaps
tell his friend now might not be the
time because you're not in a place where
you could be able to carry a campaign
off I also think that for Obama that he
has only one chance to be either a
kingmaker or a peacemaker and why would
he do that now they have a long way to
go within this primary it we could
actually see a contested convention
because of the way that new rules are
and so he could be the person that comes
in and says this is my person or he
could say okay between the two of you
we're gonna work this out and he only
has one chance to do that he shouldn't
do it now all right Greg do you have a
favorite among these Democrats uh oh
geez no you know what I when I was
looking at the at the rally there was a
keen moment there if you have this vo of
while he was talking look at this young
fella okay that's how that's how I felt
look at that I'm gonna tell you
something I don't think this is Joe
Biden's fault
I think that President Trump has ruined
rallies and politicians for everyone
even when you hear a politician talk in
that political singsong Oh talking like
this and then talking like this and then
charge it sounds so fake because Trump's
is talking like a guy a guy in the cab
talking to you and whether you like him
or not you can't listen to politicians
anymore because he's destroyed that
whole idea Alyssa Milano gave the worst
advice she said that all the Democratic
candidates should play nice with each
other no criticism okay you know what
that's like that's like a friend telling
you before you travel to some kind of
tropical jungle don't get the
inoculations you won't need them because
if you aren't inoculated to the
criticism now and before you face Trump
in the jungle you're just gonna get
eaten alive by every bug that you've
never recognized he will crush it also
creates a much more cruel environment
because all of these campaigns are so
passive-aggressive yeah I'd be
sing-songy and sweet to each other I
can't put horrific things out it's gonna
be great a shrewd political support to
the party I actually do like I like
Tulsi that's the only one I'm kind she
zigs and zags
I like people who's who I'm not if I
hear to policy positions and I can't
predict the third one that's somebody
I'm interested in I think that's why
you're interested in Donald Trump yes
yes anything career there was a recent
poll that said like more than 50% of
Americans say can't vote for Trump next
time we'll see how that works the polls